the shootings in uvalde and buffalo
remember buffalo have reignited the
debate over gun violence in this country
this year alone think about this for
just a second this is only may this is
only may heading into june there have
been 214 mass shootings and at least 77
incidents of gunfire on school grounds
again this is may heading into june dr
celine gander says using a public health
approach could maybe help reduce gun
violence and keep people safe she's an
epidemiologist and editor-at-large for
public health at kaiser health news good
to have you at the table dr gownder once
again public health approach i don't
think anybody thinks of it in those
terms but you say we need to start
thinking of this as a public health
crisis
that means that we start with the data
we
study gun violence in this country
something that was actually very
difficult to do because of something
called the dickey amendment which
restricted the cdc's ability to do this
very kind of research you need to know
where are the guns who are the people
who are at risk what are the risk
factors and how can we target those risk
factors you also say think about the
words that you use it's like when you're
a kid growing up your mother always says
use your words watch your language what
do you mean by that i think when we talk
about gun control that's a very limited
set of options in terms of reducing gun
violence it's really controlling access
to guns we should be talking about gun
violence prevention because there's a
much wider range of things we can do for
example looking at safe gun storage
getting gun shop owners involved and
educating their customers about safe gun
storage and suicide
community violence interruption programs
there's so many things we can do that
work that actually are not about gun
control 18 states and the district of
columbia have what's called these red
flag laws what are they and how can they
help red flag laws are really about
taking guns out of the equation when
somebody's in a moment of crisis it's
temporary
and families very often are in the best
position to identify when a loved one is
in crisis law enforcement healthcare
workers can also do this and again it's
really a temporary measure just until
somebody gets on the other side of that
crisis so they don't hurt themselves or
someone else we see time and time again
after a mass shooting people turn to
mental health and say this is a mental
health issue but there are people that
have mental health issues that never do
anything like this
well mental people with mental illness
are actually at higher risk for being
the victims of violence if you were to
eliminate all bipolar disorder
schizophrenia major depression tomorrow
you would reduce major violence by less
than five percent so these people yeah
they're emotionally disturbed they might
be angry entitled feeling entitled to
something or someone want revenge
but that's not a psychiatric diagnosis
are you troubled by it seems we're
hearing more and more people trying to
put the two together
it's true we we have issues with both
with mental health and with and with gun
violence but shouldn't we be focusing on
both as opposed to trying to put them
both together yeah these are parallel
crises
it's not necessarily that the mental
health crisis is directly fueling gun
violence and if we're serious about
addressing mental health the biggest
funder of mental health care in this
country particularly for these at-risk
populations is medicaid about half of
states have yet including texas have yet
to expand medicaid so if we're really
serious about mental health and mental
health care that's where we need to
start you know a lot of people are
trying to figure out what they can do
in their own communities and you you say
that there are ways that people can
strategize can legitimize their own
their own
basis of of what they're doing to help
with the gun violence issue what are
those
well there are community-based programs
so for example um cure violence
ceasefire
that focus on first identifying who's at
risk for being involved in gun violence
how to prevent the transmission of
violence because it really does function
like an infectious disease it transmits
from person to person how do you
interrupt that transmission and then how
do you stabilize people and a lot of gun
violence is actually
fueled by people who have social and
economic instability which is actually
how the pandemic is fueling gun violence
and so how do you stabilize people with
respect to housing with respect to jobs
these are the kinds of things that
really do work in communities you know
you always hear that phrase guns don't
kill people people kill people how do
you how do you look at that in the lens
of public health it's both uh you know
again using the the analogy of
infectious diseases think about
something like zika or malaria you have
the infection you have the mosquito you
have the person i mean similarly here
you don't have gun violence without both
people and the gun exactly yeah the gun
is the vector i guess
thank you dr gowner we appreciate you